το ευπουργίων ε τοσωτερικό που μας βοήθησαν έτσι να πλοποιήσουμε αρκετάεις διαδικασίες και να προχωρήσουμε
σεδούν το μέας το άλλο είναι ότι πλέον οι κεφαλικές επιδοτήσεις δεν θα δίνονται στη
βάση του αριθμού των ζώνο πως γινόταν μέχρι σημερα θέλουμε τα χρηματοδοτικά κινήτρα που δίνουμε
στους εχωπροβατοτρόφος να είναι στοχευμένα και να αποσκοπούν στην αύξηση τις παραγωγής του το εγωπρόπι
άρα θα παίρνουνταις επιδοτήσεις τους στη βάση της παραγολιικότηταςτούτσε δο πολά μεγάλες και σημαντικές αλαγες
μαζουμε πολλάαποο τοσημερι στο δαπέντα καπνται ήταν τιχημερινή περίωτον σήμερα είναι στο ίκωση της εκατω
και μέχρι τοποσιανιά απου πρίαμε την παράταση μεχριπού πρέπει αυτάς σύμφωνα με τον κανονισμόν τοσιμια
θα πρέπει να φθάνεις το πενιντα ένα τις εκατόν έχουμε πολύ δρόμο προστά μας αιιαθα
γίνιμια σημαντική αναανοδώς για ακριβώς γι αυτόν και τα μέτρα τα οποία λαμβάνουμε στο χεύουμε
στην αύξηση και το πληφιασμού καιριες παραγωγικότητας αυτό δεν μπορεί να συμβει διαμαγίας για αυτό
και ι στόχευση δεν τα καταφέρουμε δικο μαστε άλλι παράταση δι θα έχουμε προγλμάκι δεν
δε βλέπουμε αυτόν το εμπερχόμενο εργαζόαστα για να το παιτύχουμε και φάλιο νακάμας πάρχει σχέδια
για τί πούμε ήμέρα πάρχει σχέδιο για τη οπόμενη μέρα επίσης έναν πολύ δύσκολο και
απαραλμια συνέτεύξεα ότι σας βέσει να δημοσιογράφος του αρέσουν ετράτροχε στον ακάμα και είπε σε
ότι σένα τώρη τώρα μας ότ είναι αυόγια των ακάταξη εγώ των ακάνον των οραμματίζζομε
όπως ανκριβώς είναι επιστεύω τοστο μυαλών του κάθε κύπριου που που αγαπάδει να γριάδα τις
φύσις που θέλει να προστατεύει τού τον τόμο αναδικόν το ποίίο τάξι το πλάνο μας
όπως έχουμε τει πάρα πολλές φορίς ως κυβέρνηση είναι τα έργα να γίνουμε μειωμένων περιβαλλοντικ
απότύπομα υπάρχει να σχέες